there's massive opportunity to grow in
real estate using YouTube right now 42%
of people said that they were more
likely to work with a service provider
if they had a YouTube channel that's
huge this new era we need to see that we
need to see your presence online in
order to even validate you as a service
provider I think that's the new standard
other factors are certainly involved of
course you got to know your stuff and
you got to be putting in the work but it
actually accelerates them deciding if
they like you or not which is very
helpful you don't need hundreds of views
or even thousands of views on the video
you just need the right views one lead
can change your life